Mahmoud Mansour is part of a dwindling
Palestinian generation born before 1948
and what's called the nook feh or
disaster when the Israelis seized homes
and separated families for 53 years he's
been forced to live in this refugee camp
logging to breathe in the air of his
homeland
every day I think of my old neighborhood
and my family even the soil I walked on
I remember
if I had the opportunity to leave all
that I have here and go home to
Palestine I would go back even before
President Trump began announcing his
middle-east plan on Tuesday protestors
gathered in the Jordanian capital of a
man in front of the American Embassy
Jordan which has traditionally played a
role in previous peace plans had been
sidelined from discussions on Sunday
King Abdullah voiced his opposition we
have to rally support from the Arab
world the Islamic world and the
international community to hinder this
plan and look for a genuine peace
according to the international law but
the country is forced to tread a
delicate balancing act between the
competing interests of the United States
and Israel Jordan has security ties with
the United States and receives
much-needed economic aid with Israel it
has a peace treaty and beginning this
year a controversial gas deal Jordan is
also home to more than 2 million
Palestinians the largest population
outside the occupied territories I am
afraid that this deal that Trump's deal
is a very good recipe for unrest it is
intended to have unrest in the area
because if you keep unrest the Arab
countries will not have the opportunity
to develop Mansour continues to work at
the carpentry business he opened as a
young man and once thought would only be
temporary
he says Palestinians must resist
and make sure that this American
president does not determine their
destinies Natasha came al Jazeera
I'm man